ich möchte über unsere alte kanzlerin
sprechen über angela merkel die wie man
weiß jetzt nur noch wohlfühl termine
wahrnimmt während ihr land in die krise
rutscht angela merkel wurde ja immer
bezeichnet als krisenkanzlerin angeblich
weil sie krisen so meisterhaft
gemeistert hat und weil sie uns durch so
viele krisen geführt hat ich glaube das
wort bekommt jetzt eine ganz neue
bedeutung denn sie hat deutschland in
einem zustand hinterlassen der so
schlecht war wie schon seit langem nicht
mehr und zwar in der kompletten
abhängigkeit von wladimir putin sie
wurde immer wieder gewarnt dass wir
unser land weg bewegen müssen von
russland dass putin gefährlicher
diktator ist der gas selbstverständlich
einmal es war für einsetzen will merkel
wollte davon nichts wissen und jetzt
sind wir da wo wir sind und die
angekündigte zeitenwende die scholz
versprochen wird die ist auch gar nicht
da werden wir jetzt schauen wie
deutschland sich verhält wie liefern
immer noch viel zu wenige waffen weil
wir immer noch zittern vor putins
wichtigste waffe und zwar der gaza
pressung philipp ich habe ein ganz
spannendes zitat von henry kissinger der
große interview im stern ergeben oder
wurde er auf genau das angesprochen ob
die merkel kritik angebracht ist und da
hat er gesagt dass die kritik sich
eigentlich eher an die ostpolitik und
dann auch die entspannungs politik
gegenüber russland wenden müsste und die
haben einen schon willy brandt und egon
bahr vorangetrieben
und er hatte viele gespräche mit merkel
wo sein eindruck war dass ihre haltung
gegenüber russland immer auf einer kühn
abwägung von nutzen und kosten beruhte
sehr emotional war und er hat sie
eigentlich fast gelobt in diesem
interview machen wir es uns zu leicht
wenn wir jetzt sagen dass merkel schuld
ist alleine
ich habe merkel nie im persönlichen
gespräch erlebt wie herr kissen und ich
erinnere mich auch im gegensatz zu den
kissen ja nicht so gut an die ostpolitik
von bundeskanzler brandt aber wir sehen
ja das ergebnis das ergebnis ist dass
deutschland nicht ohne russisches gas
kann und das haben wir natürlich auch
der bundeskanzlerin zu verdanken die
seien nun einmal 16 jahre lang an der
macht war und sich persönlich mit großem
persönlichen politischem aufwand dafür
eingesetzt hat dass wir beispielsweise
an nordstream zwei festhalten das heißt
sie hat uns aus der atomenergie geführt
natürlich zusammen mit anderen parteien
und sie hat dann ebenfalls zusammen mit
der spd felsenfest einfach festgehalten
an nordstream 2 weil der glaube da war
dass russland uns ja immer mit gas
versorgt hat selbst den schwersten
krisen und auch genau so weitermachen
wird und das was wir jetzt sehen das ist
das ergebnis dieser politik bei diesem
gespräch das der spiegel alexander osang
redakteur geführt hat hier in berlin
dass ich mir angeschaut habe hat sie
auch gesagt sie habe immer davor gewarnt
dass putin europa zerstören will
ich muss sagen ich bin höchst politik
interessiert und bin 74 jahre alter sie
habe das alles verfolgt ich habe das nie
von ihr gehört
diesen satz der nicht wissen ich glaube
das hat sie in dem gespräch das sagt sie
habe immer davor gewarnt sie haben sich
das sicherlich auch gesehen und da habe
ich mir gedacht das hätte ich mal auch
gerne gehört vielleicht hätte ich die
ohren gespitzt weil ich auch der meinung
war wie gesagt dass auch im bund klar
dass damals die ostpolitik und ich war
bei gott kein brand 10 aber als dann von
sich aus dem straßen milliarden kritik
an die ddr freigegeben hat natürlich
aber dann aber da hatte er große
schwierigkeiten in der cs und da ist und
die lund und branntwein ich auch der
meinung bin das ist klingt jetzt platt
aber ist so lang man miteinander redet
schießt man nicht mit den aufeinander
und deswegen sagt die russen sind da im
übrigen bin ich auch der meinung wir
sollten jetzt schon überlegen egal wie
das in der ukraine ausgeht russland
bleibt russland wird nicht von der
zb ja also wir sollten das auch im
hinterkopf behalten aber frau merkel ich
bin bei ihnen weil am anfang die union
mit großer lust auf die spd mit dem
finger gezeigt hat und die außenpolitik
und der steinmeier und das sage ich
dienst führende die richtlinienkompetenz
hatte angela merkel also die union ist
genauso mit schuld wenn von schuld reden
kann an dieser entwicklung zur
abhängigkeit von russischen politik hat
das problem dass sie gerne zu dogmen
neigt also merkt wenn man hört auf die
wissenschaftler dann wann die
wissenschaftler was rausgekriegt das
finden die leute alles super weil sie
kann auch so weiter treiben dann kommt
der nächste wissenschaftler sind etwas
anderes raus also wissenschaft sucht ja
ständig und ohne zweifel gibt es auch
keine wissenschaft die wissenschaft und
politik will immer ein dogma haben und
das soll 20 jahre durchhalten und da
baum oder freude haben auch kleine
renner bei frau merkel wie sehen sie
frau merkel und auch erbe also ich
glaube dass frau merkel mehr ausgesessen
hat als man im allgemeinen wahrgenommen
hat also man wird ja irre nicht bewegung
immer für krisenfestigkeit gehalten da
mal das immer interpretiert na ja ja das
alles im griff die lässt sich da nicht
nervös machen ich glaube die hatten
einfach wieder lösung in dem moment hat
geschwiegen genau kann man so machen
weil gut aber am ende hat hier das
situation dass die probleme nicht
angegangen werden also die entscheidung
mit fukushima das war ja so blitzartig
hatte aber mehr mitarbeiten button
werden alles tun haben so ist das war ja
alles offensichtlich dass alle hier
jedoch sehen dann gab es die
arrangements mit den grünen im bundesrat
weil die in den ländern so stark
geworden sind und da hat man bei
migration und bei energie immer schön
über bande gespielt kann man alles
machen die grünen haben prinzip
mitregiert einer großen koalition das
war schon ein dreierbündnis einen
solchen wichtigen politischen feldern so
und jetzt ist die frage was hat frau
merkel eigentlich wirklich moderiert
wird das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau
also das ziel ist unklar ich hab mal
gesagt frau merkel steht auf dem schild
am steuer wieder captain nehmen
steuermann und dann hat sie vor dem
roten und weißen oder was auch immer
kleine kleinen matrosen der mit dem
denkmal lautet ob es rechts oder links
irgendwie und tiefen gibt dann wurde
besuchen gesteuert und wo der winter wo
der winter das immer noch gerade noch
gegeben zwischen den klippen so und dann
war doch die route eingefahren betreiben
so dahin kann aber nicht an alle finden
sie hatten experten die anlagen dann
geht sie raus aus den klippen und raus
aus dem nebel ozean weiter jetzt müsste
mal jemand den kurs ausrechnen dass cs
gibt auch experten sagen dass wenn
merkel noch im amt wäre der krieg nicht
scheiße und ich sage ich nicht also ich
sage jetzt mal so
angela merkel ist mit geschickt gemacht
wie man sagt wir schaffen das man habe
alle gedacht na gut dann wenn sie sagt
wird es wohl so sein aber wir vergessen
auch alle dass angela merkel das ist
zumindest meine warnung gewesen bei der
letzten bundestagswahl wo sie noch mal
gewählt würde in anführungsstrichen
eigentlich ja wenn man ehrlich ist zwar
schon auch so halb abgewählt war aber
irgendwie die konstellation ja dann
nicht anders ging und sie eben dann doch
wieder kanzlei war der park 31 kommen so
also muss man ja ganz entlassen da
draußen die menschen jetzt ja so
hundertprozentig am ende dann doch nicht
mehr von ihr überzeugt waren und auch da
ist es am ende wie beim fußball wenn
eine mannschaft absteigt dann passiert
das nicht meistens zumindest nicht nur
in der 1 saison sondern hat man auch mal
schon vorher fehler gemacht das würde
ich nur auf russland oder auf glas oder
was auch immer beschränken sondern auch
viele andere themen auch weil wir am
anfang gehört deutschland haben sie
gesagt es steht am rande am abgrund oder
wie auch immer so und wenn das wenn das
wirklich innerhalb von zwei jahren es
war sicherlich eine schwierige situation
ohne ausnahme situation aber wenn das
dann doch so schnell und so einfach geht
dann muss man sagen na ja dann hat man
das boot vorher offensichtlich doch
nicht gut genug präpariert philipp
spielt putin mit uns das ist ja auch die
ganz wichtige frage ja was wir gerade
erleben ist einfach eine kgb operation
wie aus dem lehrbuch spielt ganz präzise
mit seiner angst wir haben uns ja einige
wochen nach beginn des ukraine krieges
alle gefreut putin hat sich
verkalkuliert hieß ist putin sei
militärisch gescheitert und das mag ja
auch stimmen dass die operation dieser
krieg nicht so gelaufen ist wie ja
ursprünglich wollte aber in einem hat
sich putin nicht gehört und zwar in
unsere angst vor ihm und zwar im vor
allem in der angst von olaf scholz von
ihm dann da gab es ja telefonate und aus
diesen telefonaten zwischen stolz und
putin hat scholz die warnung mitgenommen
wir dürfen einen atomkrieg nicht
riskieren und diese angst die putin
vielleicht ihm eingeflüstert gibt er uns
jetzt weiter man stellt sich gar nicht
die frage wie realistisch ist das denn
dass es zu einem atomkrieg kommt allein
die möglichkeit die hypothetische
möglichkeit dass es so weit kommt lebt
unsere politik komplett und wir liefern
jetzt
schwerer waffen die die ukraine dringend
braucht einfach nicht wohl wie sie haben
wohl wie sie selbst gar nicht brauchen
der angst heraus dass putin eventuell
eskalieren könnte wollen wir gar nicht
wissen was das bedeutet jeden tag im
russischen fernsehen werden viele
szenarien
vorhergesagt unter anderem immer in
begleitung mit atomkrieg wäre dann der
nächste schritt aber trotzdem stehen wir
uns mehr im weg ich war kaufen zum
beispiel sehr freudvoll mehr russisches
gas auf wald und bunkern dass ein die
wir noch wissen warum also andere tun
sich da nicht so schwer also wir sind
sehr erfolgreich im dabei uns selber ins
eigene knie zu da muss ich frau
wagenknecht mal recht geben und das ist
echt selten dass ich nicht recht gebe
aber das stimmt wir sind wirklich in der
lage uns selber am meisten die frau zu
finden und da sind sie dann richtig
finden wir auch mehr russisches gas na
ja ich würde gar nicht sagen mehr aber
ich hatte jetzt schon ganz gerne also
das hat er angetönt im februar als der
krieg begann das paar habe ich frau
werbung und andere gesagt haben wir
wollen kein russisches gas mehr weil man
nicht mehr so stehen die lieferverträge
also wirtschaft funktioniert nach
solchen zeit zyklen ich habe das vorher
so deutlich zu machen wir können nicht
innerhalb von einigen monaten alles
umstellen das funktioniert nicht nicht
großflächig und jetzt ist die frage
hätte man nicht die verträge einfach so
weiterlaufen lassen diesen punkt
ausgenommen der stolz ist ja auch hin
hat das organisiert dass das gras weiter
kommt die russen liefern auch sie wollen
da gar nicht brüchig werden jetzt gab es
die schönen feine feinheit damit dieser
komponente unter wartung der haushalt
bleibe in new york ein bisschen zeit mal
die instrumente und nächste mal auf den
tisch damit alle wissen so sagen dass
die russen und schon erpressen also mit
also einfach alles so weiterlaufen
lassen wollte das stimmt ja auch nicht
wieder also ich finde ich finde unsere
ganze rolle das ist meine wahrnehmung
einfach mal jetzt so ein bisschen
vielleicht einfach gedacht ich finde
unsere rolle die wir da einnehmen
komplett falsch sondern ich finde ich
bin auch gegen diese waffenlieferung ich
bin der meinung wir liebe möchte der
muss liebe sehen und wer frieden möchte
das ist aber am ende mehr frieden möchte
der muss auch der friedensbringer sein
und wenn ich aber frieden möchte sollte
auf der einen seite sehr geehrter macht
doch mal unseren hinten stehe ich dem
anderen noch ein taschenmesser zu wie
soll das alles kann man sagen ja das ist
aber naiv gedacht am ende finde ich dass
manche sachen für mich einfach sind und
ich bin der meinung recht warum er warum
übernehmen wir nicht einfach mal eine
ganz andere rolle warum übernehmen wir
nicht einfach mal die die rolle dass ich
sag mal dass wir wollen ja das klima
wollen alles und wir retten aber warum
machen wir das nicht so wie man sagt
dass das ist das was mir ehrlich gesagt
nicht gefällt und dann bringen wir uns
selber in die bredouille dann machen wir
sanktionen und sagen so jetzt zeigen was
irgendwie auch gott jetzt kommen die
station auf einmal zurück als ja das
ganz furchtbar und dann muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ja wenn man ein bisschen
nach den kann man manches davon
vielleicht hätte man einige ist davon
auch und wir zumindest mal erahnen
können sie sich richtig ist und vor
allem das ergebnis der sanktionen ist
der rubel ist stabil so stabil war lange
nicht mehr der russischen wirtschaft
geht es gut was ist bei uns wird die die
sanktionen aussprechen bei uns inflation
so hoch wie lange nicht mehr bei uns ist
die wirtschaft was wir alle schon
diskutiert haben was also haben die
sanktionen den will dann muss ich immer
wieder schrecken der russischen
wirtschaft geht es nicht gut das stimmt
nicht da nämlich auf diese sendung
vorbereitet dann müssen alle da alle
experten alle wirtschaftsexperten falsch
liegen denn genau das sagen seine der
russischen wirtschaft geht das nicht gut
der russischen wirtschaft geht das
vielleicht nicht ganz so schlecht wie
wir gehofft hatten aber es sind allein
vier millionen menschen seit februar
ausgereist aus russland 4 millionen
meist sehr qualifizierte menschen die im
russischen arbeitsmarkt nicht zur
verfügung stehe ich glaube das nicht ja
und nicht unbedingt unbedingt dass das
ist möglicherweise eine ideologische
frage aber keine wirtschafts frage dass
die sagen hier raus und aus diesen
glücks führende land aber keine aus
wirtschaftlichen ökonomischen gründen
nein aber auch weil russland zunimmt
isoliert wurde vom ausland und sie
hatten einfach angst dass russland
irgendwann die grenze dicht macht war
dass ich glaube sie haben vorhin gesagt
russland wird auch nach dem krieg
bleiben ich glaube wir sollten dafür
sorgen dass russland nach dem krieg
bleibt aber da wo es jetzt ist und das
versuchen wir gerade zu erzielen denn
russland versucht ja ja wir wer wir
idealerweise der westen und die nato ich
glaube dieses frieden geben aber ich
habe viele draußen habe nicht das gefühl
dass die mittel die da hab ich jetzt
gewählt wurden zum erfolg führen so
einfach ist das so muss man doch mal
überlegen ob das die richtigen glaube
ich auch